Founders have a dictatorized companies
back on September 16 1985 Steve Jobs was
fired from his own company Apple Fans
like to argue that this was completely
unjust and unfair and from a moral
perspective they may be right it is
unfair to kick out a Founder from their
own company but it was also the right
decision while Apple did get destroyed
over the next decade Steve Jobs had the
opportunity to go as a leader a family
man and as a Visionary and when he
returned 12 years later he was able to
make apple into the world's largest
company looking back even jobs himself
has agreed that getting fired was the
medicine that he needed this isn't to
say that all founders should be fired
from their companies to be grounded and
put in their place but what it does show
is that even the smartest Minds in the
world are just straight up wrong from
time to time and this is precisely why
large public companies have boards
chairman shareholders and an entire
executive team the idea is that there is
a system of checks and balances that
ensures that no single person becomes
too powerful but this is no longer the
case modern companies still have a
boards and investors and executive teams
but all of that is just for show at the
end of the day the person who has all
the power is the founder or Founders now
this is no problem if we're talking
about a private company or the given
Founders have a stake of over 50 percent
but with modern tech Giants neither of
these are the case take Mark Zuckerberg
for example over the past few years he's
been gambling tens of billions on the
metaverse something that investors
haven't exactly been excited about to
make things worse much of the launched
metaverse products have flopped beyond
belief boasting as little as just 38
users all of this has given Zuckerberg a
favorability rating of just 22 or only
half of even Donald Trump this is
precisely the type of situation in which
a CEO would be fired but Mark doesn't
have to worry about that you see Mark
only owns 13.6 of meta not much more
than Steve Jobs take of 11 when he was
fired so nowhere near a majority but see
modern Founders haven't learned from
their predecessors they know what can
happen if they give away majority
control so while they may give away a
majority stake in their company they
never give away majority control how you
ask well Dave brilliantly made a
distinction between equity and voting
power while Zuckerberg only owns 13 of
meta he controls 54 of its voting power
a similar story can be seen with Google
at this point Larry Page only owns it
6.1 percent and Sergey brinham only owns
5.7 percent but together they control a
51.2 percent of Google's voting power
this means that despite having single
digits takes this Duo has ultimate
control of a 1.3 trillion dollar company
with 180 000 employees tens of millions
of investors and billions of users as
this is the story of how Founders abuse
their power this is the story of how
Founders dictatorized companies
the root of modern day Founders power is
thanks to multiple classes of stock with
different voting power class A stock
might come along with a one vote per
share while Class B stock comes along
with 10 votes per share the average
investor doesn't even realize this but
many companies actually have different
classes of stock on the public market
itself likely the best example of this
is none other than Google if you look up
Google on your brokerage you may come
across the following listing alphabet
Inc Class C ticker symbol g-o-o-g and
first it lands it looks like Google
stock the market cap checks out the PE
Ratio checks out the price looks about
right and that's because it is
technically Google stock but what it
isn't is Google stock with the Voting
Rights this means that you can buy a
billion of these shares and invest a
hundred billion dollars but you wouldn't
even get a single vote if you want
voting power you need to buy alphabet
Inc class A stock or ticker symbol
g-o-o-g-l basically everything about
this share is identical to the class C
shares except you'll get one vote for
every share that you own
but the shares that you really want are
class B shares with class B shares you
get 10 votes for every share you own but
you can look all you want on any
brokerage you can find but you'll never
find a Class B Google Shares this is
because Class B shares are reserved for
Founders VC firms and other close
insiders most investors don't look into
this too much they figure that they're a
thousand or even hundred thousand votes
won't really make a difference at the
Google and they're right as an
individual they can't really make a
difference at these companies but the
fact that one or two people have all the
votes that everyone else gives up does
make a difference and that's why
multi-class stock structures were banned
for over 50 years
you see a dual class and multi-class
stock or DCs are by no means a new
invention that's actually been around
for well over a hundred years but it was
a frowned upon invention the first
American company to issue multi-class
stock was the International Silver
Company back in 1898. originally this
wasn't considered to be a big deal
Founders wanted a bit more control over
their companies and given that
information wasn't nearly as accessible
as it is today it made sense for
investors to be more passive but over
time Founders started becoming more and
more aggressive what started off as one
extra boat became five extra votes and
then 10 extra votes and then 20 extra
votes this practice only became worse
with the Roaring 1920s as everyday
people started buying stocks they didn't
care about voting shares or earnings
reports they just wanted to be a part of
the Rockefeller fortune or the Ford
Fortune this give companies plenty of
room to test the boundaries until one
company pushed it way too far Dodge
motor company in 1925 Dodge would have
one of the most infamous IPOs of all
time they would exclusively issue shares
with absolutely no voting power this
meant that insiders could own just a
single share of stock and retain a 100
voting power and that's pretty much what
they did too the Insiders owned just 1.7
percent of the company but they had
absolute control over the company
investors were obviously pissed and this
led to an uproar on Wall Street the New
York Stock Exchange would end up siding
with investors and in 1926 they would
officially ban dual-class stock this is
where the story should have ended but
this practice has not only been revived
but it has taken over the market once
again
[Music]
throughout the next 54 years the stock
market operated perfectly fine
billionaire Foundry made it millionaire
investors were made and everyone had
completely forgotten that dual-class
stock was even a thing but this would
all change on February 8
1971. this was the day that the NASDAQ
was created if you're not familiar with
the NASDAQ you should check out our
video about them but long story short
they technolify the stock market before
the NASDAQ investors had to call stock
Brokers at the nazid to place buy and
sell orders and everything would be done
manually but with the NASDAQ the entire
stock market was slowly made electronic
Paving the road for how it is today this
was obviously the superior technology
but investors weren't impressed they
couldn't care less if quotes and trades
were electronic or not in fact they
prefer to call a broker that they knew
and trusted for for 20 or 30 years so
despite offering Great Tech the NASDAQ
struggled to get investors throughout
the 1970s to make things worse the naisy
had started ripping off nasdaq's Tech
and they were rapidly modernizing their
own systems so things looked pretty
bleak for the NASDAQ investors weren't
using the exchange and their main
advantage was rapidly disappearing so in
their early 1980s they would decide to
Pivot their strategy instead of trying
to attract investors they started going
after companies if companies were
exclusively listed on the NASDAQ
investors had no choice but to buy
through the NASDAQ with that the NASDAQ
started charging far lower fees in the
nice e for companies and they still do
this to this day but this too didn't
work you see there was a certain
Prestige and Heritage to the noisy
JPMorgan Chase wasn't going to switch
exchanges just because you charged less
so the NASDAQ was a back to ground to
zero they were worse off actually as
they were now earning lower fees as well
throughout all of this the NASDAQ
couldn't help but notice that one
exchange was actually succeeding at
taking on the noisy the AmEx not
American Express but the American Stock
Exchange one of the main factors that
distinguished the MX from the 90 was
their policy on dual-class stock the
AmEx allowed for DCS with the voting
ratio of up to 10 to 1. the NASDAQ
didn't have any DCS restrictions to
begin with but now they knew that this
was precisely what they needed to lean
into
there were two target markets with this
strategy the first was tech companies
who were fearful that investors weren't
really informed on Tech which was very
much true at the time the second was
companies that were targets of corporate
ratings if these companies were able to
distinguish between ownership and voting
power they could protect themselves from
corporate Raiders given that corporate
rating was at its peak throughout the
80s and that tech stocks would go
vertical in the 90s the NASDAQ would
also go vertical seeing this companies
listed on the naisy would threaten to
switch to the NASDAQ if they didn't
allow for DCS and with that the naisy
hadn't no toys but to unban DCS in 1986.
with that being said though companies
were pretty reasonable in the early days
in fact some notable NASDAQ companies
didn't even opt for dual-class shares
like apple and Microsoft but there is
always someone who ruins it for everyone
else and in the case of dual class doc
it was our good old friends Google and
Facebook look
[Music]
nowadays most tech companies opt for a
dual class structure because I mean why
wouldn't they the average investor isn't
even aware of it the practice has been
normalized and it gives Founders
ultimate control that's one of those
things where it's like if no one is
opposing it why would you not do it some
notable tech companies who have adopted
this practice are Snapchat Dropbox Lyft
kayak Robin Hood coinbase Zoom Roku and
TripAdvisor but this practice is by no
means limited to tech companies some
Legacy companies leveraging DCS include
Coca-Cola Ford Nike Levi and Hyatt
Hotels also don't bet on media companies
to report on this issue as the most
notable ones leverage it themselves
including the New York Times Fox News
CBS and Comcast and there are of course
extreme examples as well the Ford family
for example owns four percent of the
stock but controls 40 of the voting
power
similarly Echo star CEO Charlie ergon
owns five percent of the company but
controls 90 of the vote so let's just
say things have gotten pretty bad but I
do want to point out some notable
exceptions starting with Amazon while
Jeff Bezos gets a bunch of critique for
his practices this is not one of them it
turns out that he's actually pretty
loyal to shareholders another exception
is Elon Musk and Tesla in fact this is
why Elon was able to be forced to give
up his chairman position back in 2018
and as for our startup that's going
against the trend we have Uber so the
good news is that some companies are
doing the right thing also the S P 500
is putting up some resistance as well
starting in 2017 they ruled that
companies with multi-class talk will no
longer be added to the S P 500 this is
the main reason that many notable
startups like Snapchat have been unable
to join the index despite their size and
the given that Index Fund investing is
on the rise newer companies will very
much be losing out if they're not part
of the index will this be enough to stop
their practice altogether probably not
but it is a step in the right direction
did you realize how these Founders were
monopolizing voting power comment that
down below also drop a like if you would
like to see more videos about the inner
workings of the tech world and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as for the video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
thank you